TREVOR JOHNS: Hello and welcome
to Android Developer
Office Hours for Wednesday
October 24, 2012.
For those of you joining us this
week, or for the first
time this week, this is the show
where we normally answer
questions live from developers
via Hangouts.
And we're still going to do
that at the end, but we're
going to try something a little
different this week.
We have a prerecorded set of
questions or a prerecorded
question that we're going
to answer in depth
before we get started.
So sit back, enjoy the show,
and we'll resume the live
broadcast afterwards and
take any Hangout
questions at that time.
Play the video.
Hello and welcome to Dear
Android, the show previously
known as Android Developer
Office Hours.
We got a bit tired of developers
always trying to
show us up by asking us
questions we couldn't answer
every week.
So we decided to try a new
format for a change.
We'll be selecting the best
Android application
development questions from
across the internet, including
Google +, and answering them
for you here on YouTube.
If you're watching us live,
which is every Wednesday at 2
PM Pacific, we'll be hanging
around for a few minutes after
each episode to answer
any questions
about the current episode.
So with that out of the way,
let's go ahead and move on to
this week's question, which
comes from Danco, One Stack
Overflow, who is a
user from Poland.
He asks, if I have a custom
service that I am broadcasting
via Bonjour and that I'd like
to either broadcast or
discover using Wi-Fi
or Bluetooth, is
this possible in Android?
To answer this question we
have Alex Lucas who is a
member of our Android developer
relations team who
wrote many of the docs about
both Network Service Discovery
and Wi-Fi on our
developer site.
Alex, could you help us
answer this question?
ALEX LUCAS: Absolutely.
So to break the question into
two sub-parts, will
Bonjour-like services work
on Bluetooth and will
they work on Wi-Fi.
The answer is yes, on Wi-Fi.
No, on Bluetooth.
Thank you for tuning in.
That's our show.
TREVOR JOHNS: See ya, Alex.
ALEX LUCAS: So we should
actually, probably answer this
question in a little
bit more detail.
To start with the Bluetooth
part, Bluetooth is a really
great protocol for lots of
device-to-device applications
like streaming music
or communicating
with heart rate monitors.
But on Android, it does not
actually support TCP.
So what that means is you cannot
create a TCP socket and
connect to it over Bluetooth
to other devices.
Because Network Service
Discovery, or at least the
Android implementation of
Network Service Discovery run
over TCP, this creates a
fundamental incompatibility
between Bluetooth and TCP.
That said, it does actually
work over Wi-Fi.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right, so
before we go into a bit more
detail, let's give a bit
of background about
what exactly NSD is.
So NSD is Network Service
Discovery, which is Android's
implementation of multicast DNS
using the DNSSD, so DNS
service discovery protocol.
And what this does is it
allows applications to
broadcast to their existence
on the local network along
with connection details for that
application to any other
devices in the same proximity,
which would
be any other devices.
Again, on the same
local network.
So this is useful for things
like social applications,
games, or even network services
like printers or web
servers so that way you can find
what devices are nearby.
ALEX LUCAS: When NSD broadcasts
this information
over the network, there's four
fundamental pieces of
information it's going
to send over.
One of them is the device
identifier.
The device identifier is often
going to be either the user's
name or the device host name.
Another item is going to
be the service name.
The service name is often going
to be the name of the
application.
For instance, if you have a
game called Replica Island
that you want to play with other
users over the network
and Replica Island has Network
Service Discovery built in,
the service name is probably
going to be something like
Replica Island.
Another item is going to be the
host address, which you
don't actually have to enter
yourself at run time.
Android will just figure that
out for you and send that
along in the NSD packets.
The final item is going
to be the port.
And I want to make a special
note about the port, which is
that for mobile applications the
easiest thing to do when
you're designing the game or
the application is not
actually to pick your own
port at run time or
hard code one in.
What you want to do is get
a server socket and
set it to port zero.
And what that's going to do is
it's going to tell the Android
framework, just give me whatever
port is available on
the system.
When the server socket returns
the port number to you, you
then enter that port number
into the Network Service
Discovery broadcast.
The handy thing about this is
that if you, for instance, had
decided that you wanted port
53 to be the one your
application runs on, and some
other application developer
decided that they wanted port
53 is the one that their
application runs on, there would
never be a conflict.
And there would never be an
issue where the user had to
choose between your application
or someone else's
application running
at any given time.
TREVOR JOHNS: It's a
nice side affect.
It means you don't have to
request or reserve to port
from the IANA.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
TREVOR JOHNS: Now, you do still
have to go and register
your service name, but it's as
simple as just filling out a
simple form.
And the chances of there being
a conflict are pretty much
nonexistent.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah, very small.
You don't actually need the
IANA reservation for when
you're doing internal testing.
But as soon as you let your
application out onto the
internet to roam free, it's a
really good idea to get it
registered.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
It's just good practice.
Now, we talked a bit earlier
about Bluetooth and even
though you can't use NSD on
Bluetooth, there's another
answer that we want
to give you.
A better answer.
And that's called
Wi-Fi Direct.
Wi-Fi Direct is a peer-to-peer
version of Wi-Fi.
So it lets devices communicate
with one another without
having to go through
an access point.
This provides many of the same
benefits as Bluetooth
device-to-device connections
but with the advantages of
Wi-Fi, which means increased
speed and increased range.
This is available on devices
running Android 4 or above,
that's Honeycomb.
And if you happen to be
running Android 4.1,
Jellybean, you also get
services discovery.
Now, unlike the traditional
case of networks service
discovery, which we just
addressed, Wi-Fi Direct
discovery will work even
when you're not
connected to a network.
So think about that
for a second.
Devices running your application
nearby can be
detected even if they're
not connected to the
same network as you.
That's pretty cool.
ALEX LUCAS: What my favorite
thing about that, what that
basically means is if you're in
a movie theater waiting for
the previews to start, let's
say you've gone to the
midnight showing or something
like that, you
have an hour to kill.
You can open up the application
and see who else
in the theater or in line is
playing the same game you are
and connect to them and
play a game having no
idea who they are.
TREVOR JOHNS: It gives you
physical proximity.
ALEX LUCAS: Right, physical
proximity, which is awesome
because you know that the movie
theater is not going to
have a Wi-Fi network there.
They're probably a lot of them
these days, actually, are
designed to block incoming calls
and signals and stuff.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, but please
don't use that as an excuse to
play the game during
the movie.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
Don't play during the movie.
There's lots of helpful previews
that tell you that's
just a bad idea.
It's rude, and there'd be a
bright screen in front of the
people behind you, and we're
not suggesting that.
But when you have time to kill
in line or before the
previews, knock yourself out.
Now, we do want to point out
that it's still important to
implement network service
discovery for when you're
connected to a network.
There's a couple reasons
for this.
One of them is that Wi-Fi Direct
is not going to work at
all when you're connected to a
network because of the way the
underlying technology works.
You're either connected to a
network or your surfing around
for Wi-Fi Direct devices.
The other item is that there
are a lot of services and
hardware that broadcast services
that are designed to
be discovered on a network.
Examples of this are network
cameras and network printers.
Now, most companies will not set
up their network printers
to be Wi-Fi Direct accessible
because that means anyone who
is within physical proximity
who didn't necessarily have
permission to use that printer
could print out
whatever they wanted.
So being on the network and
requiring the user to be on
the network provides a
permission system or just a
small layer of security.
So really your best option is to
implement both Wi-Fi Direct
and NSD, and that way your
application will have the best
of both worlds and increase
the chances of your users
being able to connect to each
other no matter what
circumstance.
In order to use Wi-Fi Direct
service discovery, the
necessary class that you want
to use is Wi-Fi P2P Manager
which provides an implementation
of DNSSD
similar to the way standard
NSD does.
For more information about how
to actually implement network
service discovery and service
discover over Wi-Fi Direct, we
have a training class available
at developer dot
android dot com slash training,
and we really
recommend you go there and read
through the tutorial.
We also provide some sample
code, and it walks you through
a real world example of how to
implement this functionality
in a pre-existing application.
TREVOR JOHNS: And if you have
any questions about either NSD
or Wi-Fi Direct, join us via
Hangouts after the live
broadcast where we'll be able
to help answer those
questions for you.
And if you have any questions
for next week's broadcast,
post them to Stack Overflow or
send them to us via Android
developers at Google+ and we'll
pick the best of them
for next week's broadcast.
And with that, we'll see
you all next week.
Thanks for joining us.
ALEX LUCAS: Bye guys.
TREVOR JOHNS: And we're
back to the live show.
Hopefully, those of you watching
us live enjoyed that.
If you are here with us live,
feel free to hop onto our
Google+ Hangouts.
You can find the link by going
to developers dot google dot
com slash live, clicking on
the office hours link, and
there will be a bright
red Hangout button.
Feel free to hop on and let
us know what you thought.
Or if you have any questions
about either network service
discovery or Wi-Fi Direct we'd
love to take them now, too.
We have just a few questions in
Moderator this week so if
you want to join us in
Google+ act quickly.
We're going to go ahead and go
through the presubmitted
Moderator questions while we
wait for people to join us.
So let's go ahead and go to the
first Moderator question,
which is a little difficult to
read here but oh, so this is a
question about Android Camp and
CSSI which is the Computer
of Science Summer Institute.
It's a video question and when
we tried to play it this
morning it was actually a
private video so I don't know
if it will play now.
Let's give it a shot
just in case.
Oh, it's playing, I think.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, guys, I was
wondering if you could answer
some questions about
Android Camp.
[INAUDIBLE]
taught there this summer
or something.
But I was wondering if a high
school senior could apply to
Android Camp.
I know that sounds a bit strange
but I'm developing in
Android currently.
I'm really interested
in learning.
TREVOR JOHNS: OK, I assume that
was the entirety of the
question and didn't
get cut off.
But yeah, so the question is so
for Android Camp, which is
a program hold I believe once a
year for university students
to come and learn a little bit
about Android development.
So the question is can high
school students apply to it?
So it normally is targeted
towards university students
because we expect a fairly deep
knowledge of computer
programming in general.
It's a pretty fast paced course
so we don't have a lot
of time to go over the basics.
But that being said, if you
think you have a pretty solid
programming background
and could keep up,
feel free to apply.
No guarantees of course, but
just be sure to explain in
detail what your programming
background is and make sure
the people who are reviewing the
applications know that you
can keep up.
Now, that said there's usually,
if you're not in
college yet, there might be some
additional caveats about
being under 18.
But I'm not sure about the
legalities of that since I'm
one of their programmers.
Basically, go ahead and submit
your answer, or submit anyway.
Worst case that happens is you
get turned down and you can
always apply next year.
But we certainly love people
to apply so give it a shot.
Let's move on to the next
Moderator question which asks,
we are creating a layout
structure consisting of a
horizontal scroll view that
holds a linear layout that
will hold any number of
TextView children.
The number of content is only
known at run time and we want
all the children to
be of equal width
matching the widest.
How?
Oh boy.
So this question must have
gotten in there minutes ago,
literally, because we checked
all the questions before the
show and this was not there.
ALEX LUCAS: So is that
a horizontal
scrolling list view?
TREVOR JOHNS: Yes, it's
horizontally scrolling list
view with a linear layout
containing texts view children.
So basically, it's
a horizontally
scrolling list of text.
ALEX LUCAS: Not list
view but scrolling.
OK.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yes.
So that's a really good question
because you don't
have any of this
until run time.
Now, what I'd probably do in
this case is, when pretty much
any view gets laid out, there's
a measure children
method call.
And so if you override that, you
can modify the semantics
about how everything
is measured.
And if you need, you can either
go and force that to
return a specific measurement
or you could go and actually
fetch your list of children
at that time.
This will get called over time,
but you can fetch your
children then and make sure
you know exactly what the
correct timing with this
for your list view.
And so that way, if the default
behavior is not giving
you what you want you have
a chance to modify it.
So search for measure children
and the argument to that
should be a height spec and a
width spec, which is also a
very interesting class because
it's actually an integer.
There's a create measure spec
method that you'll want to use
to go and create those.
Yeah, I said there's a class.
It's not even a class.
It's an integer.
You have height spec and width,
I can't even talk,
Height spec and width spec both
of which are integers,
but they're not normal
integers.
They're actually, there's
a special code with the
way it's laid out.
So you always want to use create
view spec whenever you
aren't finding those.
But anyway, take a look at the
measure children method and
that should give you all the
details you need to go and
override that behavior.
ALEX LUCAS: That's much better
than my answer, which was just
going to be add a bunch of white
space to your text until
it's all the same width.
Actually, I don't even know that
that would work because
it would have to be a mono
spaced font and it might trim
while doing the measuring
anyway.
TREVOR JOHNS: So let's move
on to the next question.
Is there a way my app can be
notified when it's uninstalled
via some type of call back
URL or broadcast?
I need to be able to delete
or deregister my
users from the cloud.
Wow, this one also is a
last minute addition
to our list of questions.
Thank you for the question.
Alex, do you want to
take this one?
ALEX LUCAS: Sure.
So there is no flag or there's
no broadcast that's going to
happen when your app
gets uninstalled.
The issue there is that there
would be some security
implications to code running
as soon as it's uninstalled
especially for malicious apps.
Obviously, I'm not implying your
app is malicious but it's
a consideration we have
to take into account.
However, within the case of
wanting to deregister and
remove users from your database
in the cloud there's
a couple different
things there.
First of all, the person might
be uninstalling on one device
but not necessarily from
all of their devices.
So depending on how much space
the individual is taking up,
this might not be the right
approach to keeping your
database clean.
What you can do, other options
would include, automatically
removing for inactivity
after a year.
Or one option is actually
to use Google
Cloud Messaging, GCM.
And what you could do there is
periodically send still alive
messages, basically, to devices
where your app is installed.
TREVOR JOHNS: Actually, I have
a better idea in that case.
That's the heartbeat.
In that case, there's really
no need to use GCM.
You could just have an alarm
manager that says, OK, once a
day or once a week just
wake up and send
this ping to my server.
I mean, there's no need to
go out of your way to
use GCM in that case.
I usually like to say, GCM is
really good when you have
unplanned events.
So say NS message comes in or
your device administrator
telling a device it should
wipe itself.
I mean, these aren't things
you can account for.
And so that's where
GCM really shines.
But if it's just something that
you know should happen
once a day or once a
week, don't go with
the overhead of GCM.
Just use Alarm Manager.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
That's true.
Yeah.
TREVOR JOHNS: You have to keep
in mind, too, every time you
send a push message to a phone
it's additional network
traffic on our end.
It's initial server overhead
on your end as a developer,
and on top of that it uses up
battery unnecessarily perhaps.
ALEX LUCAS: That's true.
My mind went to GCM because we
get this question a lot with
GCM users of I don't want to
be continuously sending
messages to someone
who doesn't even
have the app installed.
TREVOR JOHNS: That brings up
another good question, though.
And so how does GCM
handle this?
If you uninstall an app that
uses GCM, how does GCM know
that that app no
longer exists?
It's the exact same problem, I
suspect, whoever asked this
question of this problem
is trying to solve.
And the answer is actually
that we don't know.
When you uninstall an app
again, there's no way to
unregister it.
So what will happen is the very
next time you send the
GCM or CTDM message to
the device it will
try and deliver it.
The delivery will fail, and at
that point we mark the device
as unregistered.
And if you try and send any more
messages after that then
you'll actually get a failure
on the server end as well.
So it's very much a lazy
deregistration once we realize
the device just doesn't
exist and we
can't address it anymore.
So even internally we run
into those same security
considerations and have to
work around them, but the
integer I don't think is
actually any worse of a user
experience.
It still works exactly
as it should.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
So I guess the summary would be
there's no way to receive a
message when the app
is uninstalled.
You can send a heartbeat from
your app and then assume it's
been uninstalled as
soon as you stop
receiving the heartbeat.
But a single uninstall by
itself depending on the
context of application, of
course, the uninstalled by
itself might not be a good
enough reason to deregister
the user and wipe their data
from your database, as they
may just be switching devices or
letting someone else borrow
the device and don't want to
have access to their personal
data available to the other
person or flashing the device,
upgrading to a different
device.
There's all sorts of scenarios
where you might not want to
wipe their data just because
the app is at least
temporarily uninstalled.
So a timeout period like six
months or a year or something
clearly defined to the user when
they set up an account,
probably a better way to go.
TREVOR JOHNS: Now, if you
do decide to implement
heartbeat, one plea.
Please, please, please don't
make it more than, I'd say,
once a day, I think would
be reasonable for
something like this.
Even once a week, maybe, once
a day is reasonable.
The reason I mention that
is, again, battery life.
Every time you have Alarm
Manager wake the phone up or
you send a GCM message to the
phone, the CPU has to run, the
radio has to wake up.
It actually on the whole
ends up consuming a
lot of battery life.
One particular wake
up is not bad.
If you're waking the phone
up every hour, every five
minutes, it adds up very fast.
So every time you wake
the phone up just
remember, there is a cost.
Keep it to a minimum for
your own user sake.
ALEX LUCAS: I would actually
go so far as to say, it's
possible to design your app such
that, if you're sending
out other network data, let's
say you're using a web browser
or something like that,
you know the
device is already awake.
You know the radio's
already on.
Take that opportunity to send
the heartbeat at that point
even if it's more than once a
day because that way you know
that you're not waking
the phone up.
You're not turning on the radio,
and you're basically in
no way affecting the user's
battery life.
TREVOR JOHNS: So shall we move
onto the next question?
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah, shoot.
TREVOR JOHNS: So the next
question comes from Terrance
in Vancouver.
Is there any way to query
information from the LTE cell
tower the device is
connected to?
Things like MCC, that's mobile
country code, MNC, mobile
network code, ECI and TAC, which
actually to be honest, I
can't remember what they stand
for off the top of my head.
So there is a telephony manager
class which will tell
you, I know definitely, will
tell you the MCC and MNC.
I can't remember about
the other two.
I can also tell you the things
like the users IMEI and the
equivalent.
IMEI is mobile identifier.
I forgot the app.
ALEX LUCAS: I think
Verizon's is NEID.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yes.
That's what I was thinking of.
So I think it's still the
same method call.
It will be like I get IMEI
or get device ID.
ALEX LUCAS: There are a lot of
three and four letter acronyms
associated with this thing.
TREVOR JOHNS: There
really are.
But yes, it's all inside of this
telephony manager class.
The one thing I will warn you
is to get access to a lot of
those values requires the access
phone state permission
which displays a very scary
warning to users.
So for that reason, I usually
like to recommend not
accessing these fields
unless you really,
really need to do it.
If you're just looking for a
way to identify the user,
usually our recommendation is
to just create a random UUID
on first boot stored inside a
shared preference file and
then read from that.
If you really do need something
that's not app
specific but device specific,
there's also an Android dot
get secure ID method call that
you can use, which is
generated the very first
time the user
starts up their phone.
Though, there are, I believe,
prior to I want to say Android
2.0, I think there were some
bugs in it that you have to be
aware of on certain devices?
I think it was prior to Froyo.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
It's pretty old.
Yeah.
I mean, it's something to keep
in mind, but there are still a
few devices out there that that
particular method call
will use, will run into.
So again, for that reason we
usually like to recommend
using a per application ID
rather than per device.
Not only that, it's better
for users' privacy.
People don't like being
tracked if they
don't really need to.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
That said, if it's the core
purpose of your application,
like one that I could think of
that would make use of this,
is I've seen community generated
reception maps where
it's on a given carrier, how
good is my reception here
versus here?
And that they basically, the
application does that by
having a few hundred thousand
people download it, and it
just tracks GPS and signal
strength and nearby cell
towers for every user
and uploads it
into a central database.
So for something like that,
obviously you want to access
this stuff.
And it's going to make sense
when a user looks at the
permission oh, they're
accessing this
information on my phone.
How else would it work?
In which case, it
would be fine.
If however, you're making a
flashlight app, it's going to
look really scary and
like you're doing
something really sketchy.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yup.
I guess I think, though, yeah,
that is definitely
a really good use.
And again, if you do need to
access that kind of data,
telephony manager is
the class you want.
So before we move on, let's take
a look at Hangouts and
see if anybody's joining
us live here.
We do have a couple
people live.
So if anybody does want to speak
live, we're going to go
ahead and unmute the mic now.
Feel free to wave and speak
up and you'll be on
the show with us.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a question.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
We have one person.
Do we have audio?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
TREVOR JOHNS: Your microphone
should be on.
You might need to
unmute yourself.
AUDIENCE: OK.
My microphone is on.
TREVOR JOHNS: We see you.
We definitely do see you but
we're not hearing anything.
Do we have both of the
audio channels here?
Try talking one more time.
Any luck?
Ah, yes.
We've got you.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: OK I have
a follow up to the
Android Camp question.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
Sure.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: For the CSSI Google
Computer Science Institute, do
you have any preference for
students with programming
experience over those without?
TREVOR JOHNS: Generally
speaking, we do.
If you have a bit more
background it
certainly looks better.
But that being said,
[INAUDIBLE]
Computer Science Summer
Institute, that ones a little
bit more basic than
Android Camp.
Right?
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
That one, I think, was more
geared toward people with
little to no programming
experience.
Whereas Android Camp is geared
more to people with strong
programming background
already.
TREVOR JOHNS: Right.
But I mean, that being said, if
you have something to show
to demonstrate interest that
always will help your
application.
But especially in that case,
we're not expecting as high a
bar as we would for something
like Android Camp.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
ALEX LUCAS: Sure.
TREVOR JOHNS: Any other
live questions?
I see at least two more people
on the camera with us.
Oh, go ahead and hit
the chat button.
They might be typing to us.
I just realized.
Sorry, we're just reading
the chat questions, now.
You'll have to forgive us.
We normally have a computer
screen in front of us, but
Daniel Pham, our usual engineer,
is traveling in
London right now and took the
studio laptop with him.
MALE SPEAKER: No additional
questions.
TREVOR JOHNS: No additional
All right.
So we'll still be around here
if anybody else is watching
live and wants to join
us via Hangouts.
Once again, go to google dot
com slash, er sorry,
developers dot google
dot come slash live.
Click on the office hours link
and there's a Join Hangout
button and we'd love to take
questions on the air.
And we'll be hanging around
until we run out of questions
on Moderator.
So let's jump back
to Moderator.
So the next question comes from
I think that's is that
Nick B in Amsterdam.
You have to forgive me if I'm
mispronouncing these names here.
My unpopular question below
slightly restated, since 50%
of the Android devices run API
10 to Google Stats, I assume
that means the status we
publish on Developer to
Internet Com, what does it mean
if you encounter a bug
like the one I cited below?
Are those bugs still
being fixed?
What about version numbers?
And so going down two questions,
I think the
question he's referring to, the
binding JavaScript code to
Android code feature is buggy
on Android version 2.3.
Will this be fixed?
That's a good question.
And I think it's one where
actually there's sometimes
some confusion about.
So generally speaking, most of
our development effort does go
into the latest Android
version.
So it's very rare for us
to go and fix a bug in
older Android versions.
It's usually only if there's
a security issue that we'll
issue an update.
Even then, it takes more often
those fixes to propagate to
devices because OEMs have to go
and create a new OS build
and have to get certified
by carriers.
So generally speaking, any bug
fixes that aren't absolutely
critical, which means they're
not security issues.
They're only going to be
addressed in the latest
version of Android.
So I know that's probably not
what you want to hear and I
apologize for that.
But that's sort of the
nature of the way
Android updates work.
We really don't have a good
way to go and update those
older devices reliably.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
Another factor is whether it's
a carrier managed device
versus a Nexus device.
So even if we did go back and
fix the bug in Gingerbread, it
could be several months
depending on which carrier or
which manufacturer or--
TREVOR JOHNS: That's why I was
saying about apps need go
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
It needs to get certified
by the carriers.
There's a lot of moving parts
unlike application development
where you just push it to Google
Play and it goes live.
The timeline from when we make
a change in code to the time
it can actually get
on a handset is
actually pretty long.
There's a lot of certifications
that happen.
There's a lot of Q&A. You
have to get approvals.
It's quite a process.
We try and get devices
out to the devices.
We manage as quickly
as possible.
Some OEMs and some carriers are
better than others but in
general, we do try and
get those updates
to phones as quickly.
I think everybody in the
ecosystem tries to get those
updates out as quickly
as possible.
But again, the older the phone
is the more difficult it is.
And at least internally in
Google, of all our efforts
goes to the latest version.
Now, I will add one
last thing.
It is possible to go back
port changes to
older versions of Android.
And I have seen that happen in
some cases where a device
manufacturer knows that they're
not going to be able
to update a phone.
Or perhaps, they're spending
their engineering time
somewhere else or the
phone just simply
doesn't support it anymore.
I have seen cases where they'll
go and back port that
one particular change without
doing a complete OS update.
So it is possible, but I'd
say it's more rare.
In order for that to happen
also, it has to be a bug
that's big enough to actually
get the OEMs attention.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
At that point, it also becomes
confusing as a developer
because then there's no way to
shoehorn in an SDK version
between, like in this case, it
would be between 10 and 11.
The SDK version's an integer so
we can't add a 10.5 for the
version of Gingerbread that
has this thing fixed.
And then, if you released your
app assuming that this
particular bug was fixed,
it would go to--
if half of the Gingerbread
devices it happened on, and
half it didn't, you wouldn't
really necessarily be able to
distinguish between devices
where your code worked and
devices where it didn't.
So in the long run it wouldn't
actually probably
help all that much.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
So hopefully that answered
your question.
Let's move on to the last
Moderator question.
This one comes from J. Dixon in
Perth, Australia, who says
we support a benevolent
organization who wishes to
donate in app purchase
content to his
customers, or their users.
They wish to pay the purchase
price, however, they can't see
a way do that in Google Play.
Is there a way to do this?
So Alex, do you want
to take this one?
ALEX LUCAS: Sure.
So there's no fine grain
solution in terms of
purchasing specific
apps on the behalf
of a different account.
What you can do, however, is
buy a Google Play gift card
and give those to the users.
But obviously, this isn't ideal
in that it has a certain
lack of control in that if
said customers are fourth
graders or something like that,
there's a chance that
instead of buying the awesome
Notetaking app, they're going
to spend it on Angry Birds.
But it's still an option, and
you can get them, I want to
say, in increments of
like $20, $25 bucks,
something like that.
That's the way I would go.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah.
So not the best solution but
unfortunately it's the only
one we have available
right now.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah.
It's the current solution.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right, so
let's switch back to Hangouts
one more time.
If there's any other live
questions we'll go ahead and
take those now.
Anybody on live question who
wishes to ask us something?
I see three people there.
MALE SPEAKER: There's
one question.
TREVOR JOHNS: OK, so there's a
text question from David Cox.
It was a little unclear from the
video, but is it possible
to use NSD and query
services over Wi-Fi
Direct at the same time?
So yeah, that's entirely
possible.
NSD will work over any TCP
connection and Wi-Fi Direct is
a TCP connection.
So normally, what you do is
you'd use, actually they work
pretty well together for that
regroup because of the nature
of Wi-Fi Direct.
But Wi-Fi Direct has an
implementation of NSD
Essentially, that it broadcasts
this service
information as part of the
Wi-Fi discovery need.
Right?
Before you're even connected.
ALEX LUCAS: We do get
into a bit of
buzzword collision here.
There's a bit of confusion in
that there's no work service
discovery that works
over a network.
It's find everything that's on
the same network as you are.
Separately from that, there's
service discovery over Wi-Fi
Direct, which is find stuff
when you're not
connected to a network.
Now, when NSD comes into play is
if you use Wi-Fi Direct and
you then connect to a network or
use Wi-Fi Direct to create
an ad hoc network between a
bunch of different devices.
At that point, NSD, Network
Service Discovery, comes into
effect because there's a network
for it to work on.
TREVOR JOHNS: Right.
So Wi-Fi Direct will help you
find other devices in
proximity that could say
they support your app.
They'll connect to them via
Wi-Fi Direct and then you'll
use NSD, the proper NSD that we
addressed at the beginning
of the video, to go and find
everything once you're
connected, which also will work
outside of Wi-Fi Direct.
If you're on a normal, regular
Wi-Fi network you'd
use the same NSD.
So hopefully that answered
your question.
So if you have any more
questions about
that, just let us know.
Next question from Terrance
[INAUDIBLE]
says, is there any way to query
information about the
LTE cell tower the device
is connected to?
So things like MCC, MNC, etc.
We actually answered
this earlier.
I don't know if you missed
the answer or not.
Unless you want to know the
specific cell tower.
The answer is yes.
All that should be
contained in the
telephony manager class.
Unfortunately, I can't tell you
the exact method names off
the top of my head.
But there is a way to go and get
a list of the cell towers
there in range.
There's a way to go and query
the active cell tower.
I will say, the MCC and MNC
are not typically--
actually no.
Excuse me.
There's actually properties
in cell towers.
What am I thinking?
But they're also properties of
the Sim Card so you have to
watch out for that too.
ALEX LUCAS: I'm really impressed
you know all of this
off the top of your head.
TREVOR JOHNS: But there's ways
to go and query all of that.
You can get it for this current
SIM card, you can get
for the current tower.
All of that should be contained
inside the telephony
manager class.
If you dig around in there
you'll find all the data
you're looking for.
Any other live questions either
via chat or via if you
have a webcam and microphone
you can hop on live to?
I'm taking the silence as a lack
of questions so at this
point I'm going to say that's
it for this week.
If you do have, actually
I'll add one last
thing before we close.
Let us know what you thought
about the new format earlier,
The Dear Android Show.
I think it worked pretty well,
but of course we care a lot
about what our viewers
think too.
So if you thought you
liked us, let us
know in YouTube comments.
If you hated it let us know
in the YouTube comments.
And assuming people like it,
I think we might keep doing
something like that
in the future.
ALEX LUCAS: And if they hate it
we just assume because it's
YouTube comments.
TREVOR JOHNS: It's true.
It's true.
ALEX LUCAS: And then we'll
keep on doing it anyway.
TREVOR JOHNS: YouTube comments
are a bit painful.
Anyway, it was awesome
chatting with
you all this week.
Be sure to send in your Android
development questions
either via Moderator or also
just go ahead and plus us on
Android Developers too.
We'll be taking a look over the
next couple of days for
the next question to
answer for the next
Dear Android segment.
We'll pick the best ones, and
we'll join you again next
week, Wednesday, 2 PM Pacific.
And one last thing, thanks to
Lewis Gray who is our producer
this week for valiantly stepping
in and keeping the
show running.
So thank you so much.
See you all next week.